we have to uh get to the bottom of a
little uh poker mystery that you're
involved in you're playing padell with
none other than uh Jamie Jamie is such a
[__]
I knew it was Jamie dude he's such a
[__] about this so go ahead so bring
that up Jamie Jamie Vernon the legend we
pulled we pulled up James we pulled up
Jamie for some padel
we're in Austin and uh and Jamie's like
listen yeah the last uh protect our
Parks I was gonna bring the story up
with me and Shane it gets heated dude
okay
the way that you know because we
are all right we were I was shit-faced
it was after a show we're at a casino
but why don't you whiff yeah with Rogan
busting with the boys Trump was just
there
so you guys are charged up yeah and Dana
and Taylor lawn are betting like big
hundreds of thousands of dollars like
per hand yeah uh but then we're at the
other like a side table we're playing a
little bit of money and
uh Jamie Gets we're playing Blackjack
Jamie gets an ace gets another Ace
splits it now he's out of money
you need somebody to help I go yeah I'll
play that I'll just play that card
playback funny how you worded it yeah
I'll play that one yeah
and then another one and another one we
got four aces in a row you can't
splitting them wow and I I ended up
paying for three of the aces he paid for
the first one
and then they all won
and I think we should have split the
winnings evenly I'd say pretty even yeah
now here's here's the question pretty it
seems I just bullied him
800 more I kept [__] with them I kept
like doing that like passive [__] where
you're like yeah I'd be like no that's
fine this one no but I think he you
should have got more 75 I did get more
eventually I did get more and he was
upset about it because
I guess in poker and gambling if
somebody backs for bets you just pay
them back what they gave you and then
about the winner no you get a little bit
you get you have to give I should have
gotten all my winners which is what I
got yeah yeah you won that one but I
think his thing was like I gotta pay him
back no matter what if I lose so he has
no risk but it was the risk though no
the that was the risk if if those hands
lost I lost those chips oh he wasn't
gonna pay me back yeah so he paid for
this you deserve all the rewards I agree
yeah I was like I'm gonna pay him back
no matter what after he won this rule is
for degenerate gambling addicts they
were like well you pay for me and then
if I win it's my money and you get yours
back I know suck my ass dude you're the
one that's out of money you need mine
exactly I won you money yeah I'm on your
side I couldn't agree more but Jamie
I did start bullying him a little into
giving me more and more and more money I
believe that and I was hammered enough
to just take it Jamie said like the Pit
Boss came by they wouldn't move on until
we were screaming we were fighting oh my
God heated eight minutes serious and I
was hammered him he said you said before
you put the money in you go hey Jamie
money's not real
[Laughter]
how much was the winning no I I don't
know I forget
I swear to God Jamie knows exactly yeah
I know Jamie knows exactly to the 34 and
I think we split it even or maybe I got
a little more than that
which one which one you should get 75
you pay percentage represent the hands
not 75 at all anyways
now we love doing Jamie's hand I'm
taking I I invited him to Ohio State
Notre Dame oh I was gonna get him his
tickets but he wants to be a [__]
you can pay for half of the ticket I
think he should
[Laughter]
all first-time users that deposit uh
unless the deposit with prize picks
you're gonna get an instant 100 deposit
match up to 100 that means you put 100
in they give in 100 as well okay very
very simple if you deposit fifty dollars
Prospect gives you 50 it's up to 100 how
does it work you pick two to six players
and if they will go more or less than
their prize picks projection you can win
up to 25 times the money on any entry
they're going to show you the lines
they're going to show you everything the
app is incredibly easy go use it listen
we already told you what we're gonna go
do you go to it's not just football they
got obviously the NFL we got the NBA the
MLB the NHL the PGA college football
men's college basketball women's college
basketball soccer wwea Esports NASCAR
tennis the whole thing and more go get
they even got Cricket yeah I'm saying
anyway see you there so prize pay has a
very generous promotion schedule
including weekly promotions like taco
Tuesday and flex Friday go after it at
prize picks you aren't competing against
other people it's just you first the
projections available you're going
against the banker who's that game where
you guys dealer no deal I know every
person watching right now believes they
can beat the game dealer No Deal you've
got it prize picks entries can be made
in 60 seconds or unless it's that easy
prize pitch is safe and it offers the
fast withdrawals you go out there you
get that money and you let them know so
you go to prize picks.com you get a
hundred percent deposit match up to 100
with the promo code Schultz Schulz go
use it
can we go back to that uh moment where
Shane was there and you're in the other
seat is that cool yeah I'll go okay